And now it's the old scout master.
Camping to me is when room service closes at 10..
If it's 10.30, I go: wow, I'm camping,
Like that survivor show.
I watch it. it's interesting to watch, but I don't understand it,
Because if I wake up in the morning and I have to look in the woods for breakfast,
you don't have to vote me off the island.
I'm putting out my own torch.
Make some real cool breeze.
Not a night of wind.
Listen through the trees.
Night of stars on my ceiling.
The glow in the dark.
Go open up the windows.
We can hear the birds in the car.
I'll put wild kingdom on my TV.
This might not be camping, but it's pretty close.
I like this primitive as you are made of it.
This might not be camping, but it's close enough for me.
Alright, so I get it.
So not everybody loves to go camping,
Not as much as we do, right?
Hey? this is podcast number 148..
Well, this is Clark Green.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
Let's take a look in the mailbag here to get things started.
Going back to podcast number 147, we talked about the first of four steps to advancement. a scout learns,
And I heard from Bill Fleming who said:
I have found that many of my scouts really learned when they instruct a skill to others.
Using the edge method has promoted this across all of scouting
And hopefully our fellow scouts are seeing the real reason behind this requirement.
We often pass the scout for completing certain requirements,
but it's often long after tender photo first class that we actually witness the skill being part of their individual skill set.
I hope you keep this great topic rolling and we will.
Thanks for being in touch, Bill,
Again about last week's podcast Mark in San Diego-
San Diego,
Get it,
Get it.
San Diego
Wrote in to say podcast 147 hit the mark with me in many ways
Right off the bat, in the opening was your quote from that paleo gearhound for his capart-
I get it,
And I sent the passage to some deserving leaders right away.
Another was a song about a woman who loves a man, who loves to camp,
And we played a little bit more of that right at the beginning of the podcast.
I think I have another tune for the slide show for my son's upcoming Eagle Court of Honor,
hopefully in about two months.
Oh yeah, I think that would be a worthy addition to an Eagle Court of Honor soundtrack. Mark,
And congratulations in advance, by the way.
Lastly, was the main topic on how a scout learns.
It's forever the task of a scout master to kind of mosey the helicopter parents away from
their sons and to let them learn the scout way.
I now have a few more phrases in my Swiss army knife of Clark quotes to help parents
understand why they should be letting their son figure out this stuff in his own way.
On another note, thank you for the explanation of advertising on your site and how it
contributes to keep it going.
I wish I'd heard this from you previously.
If I had, there were many pieces of gear I would have purchased through your links as
opposed to just going to the vendors directly online for purchases.
I will do so from now on.
Keep doing.
I'm enjoying the great work that you do
Well. thank you so much, Mark.
I certainly appreciate that.
So the song that Mark mentioned- and you heard a little bit more of it at the
beginning of the podcast- is by Christine Laban.
The title is appropriately camping,
And you also heard a little bit of Comedian John Panette's routine on
camping.
There's links to both of them in the post that contains this podcast at
scoutmastercgcom if you're interested in getting them for yourself.
Within the past couple of days I heard from Mike Malone.
Mike joined us on one of our podcasts to talk about his book
4%, the story of uncommon youth in a century of American life.
That is the kind of this definitive
Eagle Scout history book.
Now a number of you have waited patiently and I'm happy to tell you
that that book is now available in a hardcover edition.
It's a must read.
I think it's a great book.
It will be appreciated by any Eagle Scout,
whether he's just walked off the stage of his court of honor or
became an Eagle Scout decades ago.
Head on over to scoutmastercgcom and you'll be able to find a
link very easily to 4%- the story of uncommon youth in a
century of American life.
So in this podcast and Scout Master's ship in seven minutes
or less, we have our third in a series of five installments
about Scout advancement,
And you know what
That's going to be it for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we scout master's ship in seven
minutes or less?
So this is third in a series of five installments about the
four steps to scout advancement.
In the introduction
we contextualize advancement within the other methods of
scouting
And the message there is that advancement is one of many
ways that scouting helps boys.
In the last podcast
we discussed the first of the four steps to advance
it, and that is a scout learns.
We talked about that. Scouts do what Scouts do,
Not just because they're going to advance,
but because it's what Scouts do. this time around
We're going to look at the second step to advancement,
And that is a scout is tested in the
advancement and that is a scout is tested. So these four steps are: a scout learns, a scout is
tested, a scout is reviewed and a scout is recognized. So before we start talking about this,
I want to go back to something that Baden Powell said in AIDS. to Scout Mastership.
He said this: the standard of proficiency is purposefully left undefined. Our standard for
badge earning is not the attainment of a certain level of quality of knowledge or skill, but the
amount of effort the boy has put into acquiring such knowledge or skill. If he is a trier,
if he gives things a try, no matter how clumsy, his examiner can accord him the badge, and this
generally inspires the boy to go on trying until he wins further badges and becomes more capable.
Now Baden Powell went on to say: some are inclined to insist that their scout should be first rate
before they get a badge. That is very right in theory. You get a few boys pretty proficient in
this way, but our object is to get all the boys interested At the same time. we do not recommend
the other extreme, namely that of almost giving away the badges on a very slight knowledge of
the subjects. It is a matter where examiners should use their sense and discretion, keeping the
main aim in view. And then let's take a look at the most current Scout Masters Handbook when
it talks about this step in advancement, and it says this: a scout wanting to complete an
advancement requirement must demonstrate to his leader that he is fully mastered a skill
at the level expected. He might be tested by adult troop leaders or by their own patrol
leaders, troop guides or another junior leader, provided the boy leader has already earned
the rank the scout is aiming for. Completing a requirement is often more a check off process
than a formal examination. It's easy to tell, for instance, when a scout has taken part in
a required number of troop and patrol activities, when he successfully spent a night camping
out and a tent he has pitched him, or whether he can swim a certain distance. And then
our third resource that I want to bring in here is from the Guide to Advancement
2011.. And for all of you who love the numbers, it's section 2.0.0.3 and it's titled:
personal growth is the prime consideration, And it says this: scouting skills- what a young
person learns to do- are important, but not as important as the growth achieved through
participating in a program. The concern is for total, well rounded development. We know
we are on the right track when we see youth accepting responsibility, demonstrating
self-reliance and caring for themselves and others, When they learn to weave scouting
ideals into their lives, and when we can see they will be positive contributors to
our American society. As they do this, we must recognize each person's unique
combination of strengths and weaknesses. As watchful leaders, either adult or
youth, we lend assistance as called for and encourage members to help each
other according to their ability. So that's an awful lot of talking there, But I
think those are three prime references in considering how scouts are tested. Now,
what do your scouts think of when they hear the word test? I know what I
think of. You know, I see a piece of paper on my desk in school and that
piece of paper is a test, and a test is something that you pass or fail. It's
not likely that you're going to get a second chance at it or you're going
to get much credit for the effort that you extend on it. You either pass or
you fail. There's no almost passing or almost failing. That's the academic
model of learning. but we test scout requirements much, much
differently. We don't pass or fail in the academic sense. The test is not
the end. Scouts just keep doing it until they complete the challenge. An
important thing for us to understand about this step along the
advancement trail is that scouts are tested once. Once they have
successfully met the challenge of the requirement and that has been
signified by somebody signing it off in their book. that's it. The
knowledge or skill that that requirement represents will
certainly be challenged many times in the natural course of
they're doing what scouts do, but they only have to pass this
test once. When a scouts successfully completed it, it's
signed and he's never going to be tested on that particular
requirement again. In my 30 plus years of scouting I have yet
to see anyone collude with a scout to certify a requirement that
he's not actually completed. I've never seen that happen. I've
had my doubts that the requirement was understood or
evaluated correctly, but never that it was just out and out
bypassed by a lie. In the rare instances where I find that
someone may have misunderstood a requirement, we don't penalize
the scout. The signature always stands Once he's been
tested and the book is signed. that's it. What I will do on
those rare occasions is I'll speak to whoever signed the
requirement and help them better understand the
responsibility involved and encourage them to become a
better examiner, And scouting is designed that way. We
trust the signature. If we don't trust individuals, you
know, the atmosphere of mutual trust and respect we
predicate all of scouting on begins to come into
question. So just to bring this home, a scout is tested
once. Now he can challenge a test many, many times, but
once he has successfully passed that requirement and it
signed, it's done. Now, if we go back to what the scout
master handbook had to say, there are basically two
types of tests. The first is what the scout master
handbook calls this check off process. A lion's share of
tests for requirements are really just a simple
certification of what the scout has done, as a
representation of what he's able to do. So he either
did or did not attend a camping trip or swim a
given number of yards or anyone of a dozen different
things, And once he's completed those things they
get signed off and he's done. The second is what the
scout master handbook implies is a formal examination
And I would call, I would define this as those
instances where judgment is required on the part of
whoever's certifying the requirement to determine
whether the scout has completed it or not. So these
kind of requirements require someone to make a
judgment call And there's some important concepts to
apply to these kind of judgment call requirements
And these concepts I think were described pretty
well by Baden Powell. He said the standard of
proficiency is purposefully left undefined. When
testing a requirement requires judgment when
it's not just a simple polarity of yes, a scout
did this or no, he did not. There's really no specific
standard of proficiency. What we want to learn in
evaluating these requirements is what the scout knows
and what he's able to do based on the effort he's
extended. The scout master handbook says that a
scout has fully mastered a skill at the level
expected And that level is different for every
scout because we are recognizing each scout's unique
combination of strengths and weaknesses. We're
looking for total, well-rounded development.
We know we're on the right track when we see them
accepting responsibility, demonstrating self-reliance,
caring for themselves and others, and that they
learn to weave scouting's ideals into their lives.
That's the kind of concept we need to apply to
making these kind of judgment calls, And I think it's
very important to understand whose judgment this gets
to be. Now we've arrived at one of those things in
scouting that causes a lot of contention: Who gets to
make a judgment about whether a scout has
completed a requirement or not? I think it's
important to invite the scout's own judgment
into the question of evaluating this. So if a
scout has come to me and said: I need to get,
I need to be tested in this requirement, I need you
to sign this off for me. I ask them to read me
that requirement and then I ask them what they
understand about that requirement. I go on to
ask them if they think they've met it and to
explain how they make that judgment. Sometimes I'll
ask more questions that help them discover
things that they may not have understood about
it, And I do this to keep the main aim and
view- Remember Peyton Powell talked about that.
to keep the main aim and view, Can this scout
exercise the kind of integrity to evaluate
himself fairly. Is he weaving these concepts
into his character? Is scouting enabling him to
learn these important things in life? So this
makes the scout himself responsible for
evaluating himself. It's a guided discussion.
We ask lots of questions, we go through it
and we let them make the final determination
whether or not they've completed that
requirement. It kind of turns things a
little bit on its head from what a lot of
us are used to doing. I would encourage you
to give it a shot, see how well it works. I
really depend on it. I think inviting the
scout's judgment into the question is a
very important thing for us to do. The
other aspect of these kind of judgment
calls are two extremes that Peyton Powell
described. One is almost giving badges away
on a very slight knowledge of the
subjects. The other is to insist that
our scouts should be very first rate
before they can get a requirement.
Between those two extremes, Peyton Powell
describes kind of a middle path, a right
way, and he says examiners using their
sense and discretion, keeping the main
aim in view. Now, the main aim is put
succinctly in the Guide to Advancement.
I'm going to repeat it for a third time.
We know we're on the right track when
we see youth accepting responsibility,
demonstrating self-reliance, caring for
themselves and others, and when they
learn to weave scouting ideals into
their lives, and when we see that they
will be positive contributors to
American society And that's really
everything right there. That is what we
want to be looking for. That is the aim
that we want to keep in view when we're
going through this testing part of
advancement. Finally, we need to
understand that none of us individually
owns advancement. We don't own the
awards. I've never personally sat down
and embroidered a Marriott badge patch
for presentation. I've never personally
sat down and written out all the
requirements for a Marriott badge.
We don't add or subtract from the
requirements. It's not our responsibility
to protect them from the unworthy.
What our responsibility is is to keep
the main aim in view. If we go back
over the history of scouting, if we go
back and we start in 1910, if we go
back to the earliest years of scouting,
we're going to find adults getting
frustrated with the quality of scout
skills. It comes up again and again.
It's nothing new. Getting frustrated is
a pretty good indication that we may be
missing the whole point of what we're
doing, or the main aim, If a scout can't
tie a square knot weeks or months after
he was tested and approved as having
attained that skill. some of us are
going to see it as a deficiency in
instruction or a laxity of standards
and really the impending end of any
kind of integrity in scouting at all.
If our main aim was producing boys who
could tie square knots on demand, I'd be
worried about that.
Thankfully that's not our main aim.
Obviously we want the best for our
scouts. We really want them to learn
things In some measure. their performance
is also a reflection of our own work,
right?
So it's possible that a tinge of
selfishness clouds our judgment when
we get defensive and we try to protect
advancement by insisting that scouts
be first rate. As Baden Powell said,
this is all very right in theory, in
theory.
So if we get misdirected by this idea
that high proficiency in scout skills
are our aim, that's very right in
theory.
But what it does is it leads to some
very negative things happening. We
start to crack down on the slackers
and tighten things up and we get pretty
intense
about making darn sure that we aren't
giving any requirements away
And we get this kind of golem-like
preoccupation with the precious,
this state of rigorous perfection, and
that diminishes the joy of scouting
for us
and for our scouts, and it's just
plain frustrating.
If we think about what Baden Powell
said and we dedicate ourselves to
keeping the main aim in view,
we learn that this kind of dogged
pursuit of perfection is having
really an absolutely opposite effect of
what we'd hoped it would produce, and
that is happy skilled scouts.
Okay,
What we
end up doing is producing,
perhaps, scouts who can tie square knots
on demand,
but they are deriving from the program
what the program
is aimed at.
F Darnell Daly Jr
is the Advancement Chair for Area 6
of the Northeast Region
and he wrote something that has been
circulating around for quite a while
now and many of you may be familiar
with it,
and it's a. it's a little writing called
Guardians at the Gate
and I want to read a little bit of it
to close out this installment.
He says: some of you appear to be
standing guard at the gate.
like good guards, you are not letting
anyone pass
who does not have the correct
password.
When someone appears at the gate who
does not have the correct password, you
send them away.
The treasure that you believe you are
guarding is the sacred
advancement requirements.
You believe that you must guard the
gate to make sure that no boy
advances
who has not only met the requirements
but who has met the requirements 110
percent.
Your watchword is:
we've gotten soft on Boy Scout
Advancement.
The problem is that you've got your
orders wrong.
you're guarding the wrong side of the
gate.
The treasure is not behind the gate
but in front of it.
The treasure is the character of the
boys in our care.
Your duty is not to prevent boys from
passing through
but to make sure as many boys as
possible
do pass through.
I'll have a link in the post that
contains this podcast to that complete
quote.
It creates a picture that I think
really helps drive this home.
So a scout is tested.
a scout gets tested once.
He can challenge a requirement as many
times as necessary.
Some requirements are certified
through a simple check off process,
Some require some judgment.
If we invite the scouts
personal judgment into the question,
it will help both them and us.
And finally,
we don't want
to follow either extreme
of just giving stuff away
or
guarding the gate.
We want that middle road
where as many boys as possible do pass
through that gate,
And we do this
by keeping
the main aim
in view.
So in the next podcast we're going to
talk about step number three
in scout advancement,
that is, a scout is reviewed.
Love to have you get in touch,
and you're going to find out how to do
that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for listening to this
edition of the scout master podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the scout master blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can
subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can also subscribe to the scout
master podcast on iTunes
and you can access the podcast on any
mobile device through Stitcher
smart radio.
Get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
You can call in and record a shout out
to be included in a future edition
of the scout master podcast.
Again, go to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the shout out link
and you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Follow us at scoutmaster blog
on Facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on Google plus.
You know you can also email me,
Yep, if you don't deal with any of that
panorama social media, blah, blah, blah.
That's right.
Email me, Clark Green, with your comments
and questions
at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
It's now time for me to tell you
that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and perhaps have a little bit of fun
along the way.
So let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.